[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض
تتواصل حرب اوكرانيا الجوع تتسيد نقاشات
واجتماعات القدم
والسلوك الايراني
اوله بنك للبذور في السعوديه يوصل
مستهدفاته رعايه 600 الف بذره في العلا
حتى 20 30
رياض تجمع خبراء التقنيه في بلاك هاد
جوائز مليونيه تنتظر
250 فريقا سبراليا
رحيل محمد السنوسي وزير اعلام الكويت
السابق واحد رواد التغيير في حياه
الكويتيه
نواصل وتغطياتنا لقمه مجموعه العشرين في
جزيره جبال الاندونيسيه التي تتم يومها
الاول
لملف الازمه الاوكرانيه على طاوله النقاش
ودعوات لوقف الحرب التي قد تتحول الى حرب
العالميه الثالثه
استخدام الاسلحه النوويه والتهديد بها غير
مقبولين وجاء في المسوده ان معظم الاعضاء
يدينون بشده الحرب في اوكرانيا دعيتان الى
ضروره التمديد صفقه الحبوب الاوكرانيا
واضافت المسودان المجموعه تبدي انشغالها
بتاثير الحرب في اوكرانيا على الاقتصاد
العالمي وخلال افتتاح القمه حب رئيسه
الاندلسي ودودو قاده المجموعه على انهاء
الحرب وتجنب حرب الاخرى بين القوه الكبرى
في هذا الاطار وكده وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
مع او نو منعت السيسي البيان الختامي لقمه
العشرين مشددا على ان بلاده جاهزه للتفاوض
لكنه اوكرانيا هي التي ترفض التوسل
الاتفاق وذلك لان الدول الغربيه تامر
الرئيس
فلاديميرسيلنسكي بعدم الدخول في مفاوضات
مع موسكو لان الولايات المتحده والنيتهم
منخرطان في الحرب على اوكرانيا على احد
تعبئه وقال لابره بنتهامه روسيا بالعدوان
على اوكرانيا استفزاز مقصود لكن في ذات
الوقت اشار الى ان هناك الكثير من الدول
لم تنضم للعقوبات ضد روسيا مضيفا بان
عمليه تروسي العسكريه في اوكرانيا مشروعه
لكن الرئيس زينكي لا يريد السلام
من جانبيه شدد المستشار الالماني واللاف
على ان افضل طريقه لتعافي الاقتصاد
العالمي هي انهاء الحرب الروسيه في
اوكرانيا واشاره شورت خلال جلسه لقمه ال
20 بشان امن الغذاء والطاقه بان الحرب في
اوكرانيا لها تداعيات وخيمه ويجب وقفها
فورا
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
الذي يشاركه في قمه العشرين بدا لقاءاته
مع قاده العالم حيث استقبله اولا رئيس
الاندلس ودودو الامير محمد بن سلمان التقى
ايضا الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان على
هامشي قمه ال 20 المنعقده حاليا في بالي
كمل تقى ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان على هامش القمه برئيس وزراء
بريطانيا ريتشي سوناك وعبر سوناك عن امله
بمواصله بلاده العمل مع السعوديه من اجل
استقرار اسواق الطاقه سونيك وولي العهد
السعودي اعرب عن قلقهما تجاه التهديدات في
المنطقه بما فيها سلوك ايران
كمستعرض ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان العلاقات الثنائيه وعددا من
الموضوعات ذات الاهتمام المشترك مع رئيس
دوله الشيخ محمد بن زايد
من بقالي هي ينضم الينا موفد العربيه محمد
الطميحي برفقه ايضا موفده العربيه فاطمه
الضاوي مرحبا بكما فاطمه ومحمد اهلا بكم
ما في نشره الرابعه دعوني فقط ان اضع
العناوين العريضه ربما لهذه المداخله لكم
في بالي هذه القمه تعقد وسط مهددات متعدده
للاقتصاد العالمي بدء بارتفاع التضخم ازمه
الطاقه نعدم الامن الغذائي الركود العالم
المحتمل الحرب التجاريه الامريكيه همم
الصينيه ولا اضطرابات الجيوس السياسيه
الشديده التي خلفتها الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه هل يمكن لقمه بالي استعاده
الزخم الاقتصاد العالمي ام انها ستكون
يعني مجرد قمه اخرى لا اكثر من ذلك تفضل
خالد اهلا بك واهلا بمشاهدي الرابعه
السؤال جيد ااا
كان مجموعه السبع اللي بتمثل الدول الاكبر
اقتصادا في العالم كان دائما يكون عليها
تعويم انه يصدر منها مخرجات ولكن الصوره
تغيرت خلال ثمان سنوات الماضيه بالارقام
اذا ما تحدثنا فقط عن مساهمه الناتج
المحلي للصين في الاقتصاد العالمي فهو
مرتفع او بشكل تقريبا بحسب الارقام
الرسميه حوالي
38.6
بينما امريكا والولايات المتحده بتساهم في
مجموعه اقتصادات مجموعه السبعه فقط بحدود
18.6% فنعم الصوره تغيرت ثقل اقتصادات
مجموعه العشرين اكبر بكثير مما هو ممثل في
جي تي جي 7 وبالتالي هناك وهناك الكثير من
الامال المبنيه لعل على الاقل الاتفاق انه
نحن في ازمه استثنائيه استمرت للسنوات
بداناها من كرونا ودخلنا في حرب روسيا
اوكرانيا تداعيتها كانت قويه على جميع
اركان الاقتصاد العالمي بالاضافه بالطبع
الى امن الطاقه وامن الغداء نعم
بشكل قوي جدا في الكلمه الافتتاحيه لقمه
العشرين اليوم عندما تحدث الرئيس
الاندونيسيا ارجوكم عندما تحدث بانه لا
يمكن القبول بان تكون هذه القمه مجرد بشكل
او باخر حبر على ورق يريد ان تكون هذه
القمه قمه بالي تغيير جذري فيما يتعلق
باتخان قرارات لانقاذ العالم مما قد
ينتظره من مشاكل الاقتصاديه من ركود
اقتصاده عالمي خاصه في السنه المقبله اذا
لم تتخذ قرارات قويه ولافته ولكن يبقى
سؤال الاهم هل بالفعل اتخذت هذه القرارات
مخنوق بانتظار البيان الختامي كل
التسريبات التي تتحدث كانت تسريبات في
معظمها ربما تسريبات سياسيه تتعلق بلزمه
في اوكرانيا تتعلق بامن القدام امدادات
الطاقه ولكن على هامش كل هذه الاجتماعات
وكل هذه اللقاءات يبدو بان الحدث الابرز
واللافت الذي يؤمن عليه العالم كثيرا هو
التقارب الصيني الغربي شاهدنا اجتماعات
ليست فقط اجتماع بايدنج ولكن هناك
اجتماعات اخرى جماعته بماكرون جماعته
برئيس الوزراء همم الاسترالي اذا هناك
اكثر من حل اكثر من ازمه نتحدث عن ازمه
تايوان المحيط الهادي نتحدث عن العلاقه مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي كان ايضا اللقاء مع
مسؤولين اوروبيين اخرين انطلاقا من اللقاء
الذي جمعه مع رئيس وهذه نقطه تحول ربما في
قمه العشرين
من جهه القوه من يملك القوه اليوم هذا هو
الذي يجب ان القلب جواب اللي ملك قوه هو
اللي عنده يلعب دور رئيسي في الاقتصادات
والان هي الصين الصين اصبحت اا او لاعب
رئيسي لا يمكن ان نهمشوا او نعطيه اوامر
لكي يتحرك على اساسها ونجحت الصين في ذلك
اذا ما ياتي بايضا بعد سنوات ان الحكومه
الامريكيه كانت تهاجم الصين وتهددها سواء
على موضوع الرقائق او السمكه او تايوان او
ساوثريه وتقول نحن الان مستعدون لايجاد
حلول ونبني منصه لبناء علاقه ثنائيه صحيه
ايضا الصين لربما الان تمشي نحو تحقيق
اهدافها الاستراتيجيه وايضا السياديه
والاقتصاديه ان تبقى لاعب رئيسي في
الاقتصاد العالمي مقتله مهمه ايضا انه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه زارت انه دور
اسيا اصبح مهم جدا وهذا يؤكد الجوله
الاسيويه التي يقوم بها
ولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان بدءا من
همم من هنا من همم من بالي انت مسافر بكره
ولا اليوم غدا ربما حتى الان لتغطيه زياره
اخرى زميره ميسون وايد من العربيه ايضا في
تغطيه في كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان وهذا
يقودني ايضا الى الاجتماعات الثنائيه التي
عقدها الامير محمد بن سلمان اليوم هنا في
بالي بدا من استقبال الرئيس ودود له في
قاعه همم مجموعه 23 او القاعه التي عقدت
فيها اجتماعات مجموعه العشرين كان هناك
لقاء لافت له ايضا مع رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني همم
تحدث فيها عن موضوع الاتفاق على الا تكون
ايران مهدد للاستقرار الاقليم في المنطقه
في النووي واكيد ام الطاقه وهذا اول لقاء
يا جماعه طبعا مع ولي العهد الامير محمد
بن سلمان كان هناك ايضا مع رئيس دوله
الامارات العربيه المتحده الشيخ محمد بن
زايد ولا ننسى اللقاء الذي جماعه ايضا
رئيس رجب طيب اردوغان ولكن ايضا اللقاءات
الجانبيه التي عقدت سواء في قاعه الاجتماع
او في حفل الغداء او في حفل العشاء الذي
شاهدناه قبل قليل نلاحظ ايضا اجتماعات
ثنائيه وحديث جانبي اكثر من مره تكرر
الحديث الامير محمد بن سلمان مع الرئيس
الفرنسي مكرون مع
المستشار الالماني شغل ايضا مع عدد من
المسؤولين كما تابعنا في اللقطات بمن فيهم
الرئيس الصيني همم
بنك بالمناسبه كيف تابعت يا فاطمه عرض
الختامي لليوم الاول من همم القمه خاصه
فيما يتعلق باحتفال الرئيس وجوده
بالمشاركين في قمه العشرين
مثل اللي لابسين الرؤساء خالد دخلوا همم
قادت دول مجموعه ال 20 وكل واحد لابس قميص
من الطراز الاندلسي بلون مختلف هم بيحبوا
الالوان شويه تكون فاقعه يا اما اصفر يا
اما فوشيا يا اما بينك احنا حاولنا انه
ههه
[موسيقى]
طيب انا خلوني فقط
عن هذه القمه وما يمكن ان تتمخض عنه يعني
يمكن في 2015 بعد
حرب القرم وانا هنا تتحدث على الجوانب
السياسيه اللي كان لا تاثير على الجوانب
الاقتصاديه بشكل كبير على على كل الجوانب
الاقتصاديه النمو غيرها من الامور وعان
العالم وما زال
اليوم في حال لم
تكن هناك حلول ربما للحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه
واذا كانت هناك مشكله اخرى ربما تاتي
نتحدث عن احتمالات ان ان يشهد العالم كذلك
حرب اخرى قد تكون اقصى واصعب اللي هي حرب
صينيه او حرب الصين هنا كيف يمكن ان يتضرر
الاقتصاد العالم والى اي مدى هناك تعاطي
من خلال هذه القمه مع هكذا احتمالات خطيره
همم محمد همم وفاطمه
خالد لربما تصريحات اللي سمعناها من
القاده خلينا نبدا بالصين ذكرت همم مخاطر
الحرب الصينيه مع تايوان هذا اتى على لسان
تشيجن بيج انه فعلا الان سوف يراجع هذه
العلاقه وانه بدا يسمع الى الجهات الغربيه
او الولايات المتحده بايجاد علاقه او
خلينا نقول معادله لاعاقه الجديده اللي
هيرسمها مع تايوان وبالتالي هذا السوق
وشوفنا الاسواق الاسيويه مرتفعه صباح هذا
اليوم كان في تفاعل قبل المستثمرين اللي
راقبوا هذا الاجتماع اللي اول من نوعه منذ
تولي ايضا للاسد الولايات المتحده همم
اشاره ايجابيه انه فعلا الصين انه العلاقه
بدات تتغير الافضل هذا من جهه من جهه اخرى
همم على حسب التسريبات في مسوده
البيان الختام المفروض يصدر غدا انه
اول مره بنشوف لربما التحذير او اجماع من
معظم اعضاء مجموعه العشرين بدينه الحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا
تدان الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا معظم
القاده وبالتالي خرج وزير الخارجيه الروسي
وتحدث عن ان هناك محاولات
لادانه روسيا بشكل مباشر وبالتالي لن يصدر
بيان من هذا النوع الكل يتحدث عن الحل
السلمي» كيف هذا هو الحل هذا هو الاختلاف
وبالتالي انهاء الحرف اوكرانيا الجلوس الى
طاوله المفاوضات ولكن ليس كما يريد
الاتحاد الاوروبي ليس كما تريد الولايات
المتحده بادانه وواضحه لموسكو فيما يتعلق
بهذا الحرب ولكن هناك ملفات نختم بهذه
ملفات بارزه فيما يتعلق بالاتفاقيات
ثنائيه الجانبيه التي تساهم بشكل كبير في
تراجع تضخم في مساعده الدول اكثر فقره
فيما يتعلق بالدور الذي تقوم به مجموعه
العشرين وليس فقط الازمه في اوكرانيا
والعلاقات مع الصيد
ايضا تكررت كثيرا وبالتالي نتامل انه هذا
الاجتماع في بالي جزيره الالهه كما يصفها
السياح والاندونيسيين يطلع منها نتيجه
ايجابيه هذه المره
ونعود بشكل اقوى كما تقول قمه ال 20 في
بالك خالص شكرا جزيلا لكم بالتاكيد همم
يتابع معكم الزملاء فينا شراتاه لاحقا كل
تطورات هذه القمه من بالي محمد الدميحي
وفاطمه الضاوي
التزامل مع قمه العشرين كده السفير
الاندونيسيه لدى السعوديه الدكتور عبد
العزيز احمد في مقابله مع العربيه ان
العلاقات مع السعوديه
[موسيقى]
تركب برنامج يعني هو ربي يسابق الواسان
غدوه النجاره
من امريكا
رابع مستمره في بعد قليل على اساس شهرين
انخفاض التضخم في السعوديه الى 3% في
اكتوبر الماضي
اهلا بكم جيد كشفت بيانات الهيئه العامه
للاحصاء في السعوديه عن انخفاض معدل
التضخم في البلاد خلال اكتوبر 2022 الى 3%
مقارنه سبتمبر المهدي واظهرت البيانات
تسجيل ارتفاع طفيف بمؤشر اسعار المستهلك
لشهر اكتوبر الماضي بنسبه صفر واثنين من
10% مقارنه بالشهر السابع
من خلال هدف يدعو الى رعايه
620 طبيعيه
من مشتل وبنك البذور في العلا ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه سعود الخلف سعود مرحبا بك
يعني ليه تعطينا فكره اكثر او اضاءه اكثر
على هذا البنك بنك البذور في محافظات
العراق
في العلا وطبعا هذا البنك والمشتل يهتم
بتوفير الغطاء النباتي ل همم يعني حمايه
الطبيعه وايضا يعني لو بنشبهها خالد مثل
همم حمايه الحياه الفطريه كثير من
الحيوانات انقرضت ولكن حمايه الحياه
الفطريه بدات في عمليات همم
همم السعي الاكتشاف اماكن هذه الحيوانات
التي يعني شاركت على الانقراض وبدات في
العنايه فيها همم بنك البدور نفس الفكره
ولكن بشكل اكبر عندما يعني يقوم بتوفير
وتامين الغطاء النباتي فهو يحمي النباتات
ويحمي ايضا الحيوانات التي شاركت على
الانقراض هم يقومون بجمع البذور لانباتات
والاشجار والعنايه بها حتى يعني تصل الى
مرحله ان تزرع في اماكن اخرى او تنقل الى
اماكن اخرى في تفاصيل كثيره خالد همم ما
راح اقدر انا اتكلم فيها ولكن اسمح لي انه
يكون معي المهندس سامي المالكي وهو مدير
اداره همم
البستنه ومشاكل النباتات في الهيئه
الملكيه للعلا يعطيك العافيه
هذا البنك يعني احنا تكلمنا انه هو يهدف
الى توفير الغطاء النباتي ولكن اكيد هنالك
اهداف اخرى نود تطلعنا عليها اول شيء
السلام عليكم حياكم الله جميعا الحقيقه
تنميه المبيعات الطبيعيه جزء اساسي من
النمو الاقتصادي في محافظه العلا بالاضافه
الى جهود الهيئه الملكيه لمحافظه العلا في
حمايه التراث الطبيعي للبلاشك يشمل
النباتات ويشمل المحافظه على اصول
النباتيه الموجوده في المنطقه اللي فوق
عدد الانواع النباتيه الموجوده في محافظه
العلا اكثر من 400 نوع نباتي وما زالت
الاعمال مستمره في تسجيلها ورصدها ونتوقع
المزيد باذن الله تعالى
فهذه تقريبا اهم ال- المستهدفات
الاستراتيجيه للمشتل النباتي وبنكور حمايه
الوصول الوراثيه حمايه التراث الطبيعيه
وكذلك المساهمه في الاقتصاد الطبيعي
وتنميته في محافظه العليا يعني فيها
نباتات معينه ومستهدفينها ولا جميع
النباتات اللي موجوده يعني تنبت في البيئه
المحيطه للعلم احنا بنستهدفين النباتات
البريه بالدرجه الاولى لان هي النباتات
اللي من البيئه او قادره على على استعاده
البيئه مره اخرى بشكل ناجح ولذلك استهدف
هذه النباتات البريه وصلنا الان الى اكثر
من 60 نوع نباتي بدانا ب 10 انواع نباتيه
ولا وصلنا 60 ونطن معه ان شاء الله في
السنوات القريبه القادمه نصل الى ال200
نوع نباتي وبعد ذلك الانطلاق للمرحله لو
ساعدنا الله في انقراض للنباتات والحساب
في مظاهر تصحر مظاهر تصحر دائما قد تؤدي
الى انقراض او تؤدي الى الحصار لهذه
النباتات ولذلك هذه الجهود جدا ضروريه في
الوقت الحاضر الحد من المظاهر التصحر
واعاده الغطاء النباتي باعاده توطين هذه
النباتات مره اخرى في البيئه المحليه
همم يتم جميع البذور هي عمليه بتتم بشكل
شبه يوميا فريقا المختصين اا يذهب الى
اماكن محدده سواء في الاوديه او في الحرات
ويجمع البذور من اماكنها الطبيعيه في
اوقات محدده لكل نوع نباتي بطريقه معينه
ثم يتم احضارها الى المشتل بعد عمليه
المعالجه والتنظيف ثم بدا عمليه اختبار
نسبه الحيويه واختبار قدرتها على الانبات
ثم عمليه تجفيفها في مجفف بارد لمده
اسبوعين الى ثلاثه اسابيع ثم المرحله خير
مرحله التخزين اللي يكون في درجات حراره
منخفضه تصل الى ناقص 10 وناقص 15
الاخير هل همم يعني العمليه تتم للمناطق
القريبه من العلا امس تشارك في مبادره
السعوديه الخضراء العلا جزء من مبادره
السعوديه الخضراء وكل مشاريعها في حمايه
المناطق الطبيعيه وتنميتها هي جزء من
المباد الوطنيه للسعوديه الخضراء واحنا في
في عجله دائما للوصول الى المستهدف 10
ملايين شتله تزرع في المحميات الطبيعيه ان
شاء الله بيحلوا العام 20 35 ان شاء الله
يعطيك العافيه الله يعافيك يا رب هذه نبذه
سريعه عن البنك وان شاء الله يعني مثل ما
قال المهندس مع 20 30 تكون يعني الارقام
عاليه جدا في عمليه المحافظه على الغطاء
النباتي السعوديه شكرا جزيلا لك من
المشتركه
العربيه السعوديه
تمور اكبر منتج غذائيه تصدره السعوديه الى
الخارج قبل سنوات قليله دشنت او دشنت
علامه تمر السعوديه احدى مبادرات المركز
الوطني للنخيل والتمور التي تعنى برفع
جوده الانتاج في قطاع النخيل والتمور
يعرفنا اكثر على علامه النور السعوديه
اكبر مصدر للتموري حول
العالمه تمور السعوديه التي ادت لزياده
قيمه صادرات المملكه من التمور بنسبه 36%
من اجمالي قيمه الصادرات علامه التمور
السعوديه بمثابه وسم يقيموا سلمه المنتج
وجودته وفقنا عيره عالميه في الممارسات
الزراعيه والصناعيه وضماني سلسله الامداد
ضمن ثلاث تصنيفات الاول تصنيف ممتاز للحبه
الكبيره والتصنيف اول لحبه التمر المتوسطه
واخيرا تصنيف ثاني للحبه الصغيره نسبه
امتثال المزارع والشركات المختصه بانتاج
التمور لهذا التقييم تجاوزت عتبه 40%
مئه وسبعه وخمسون مصنعا للتمور تتواجد في
السعوديه تغطي نحو ثلاثه ملايين نخله
تستهدفها علامه التمور المصانع الحاصله
على علامه تمور السعوديه تحظى بعدد من
المزايا منها اولويه مشاركه في المعارض
المحليه والدوليه الخاصه بالتمور فضلا عن
تسهيلات اخرى لزياده فرص التسويق والتصدير
على سبيل المثال يتم انهاء مخلصتهم
الجمركيه لتصدير واصدار الشهاده النباتيه
لهم باقل من ساعه بدلا من اربعه ايام عمل
كما في السابق
وتحظى مشاهدينا مزارع التمور بخصم على
الخدمات يصل ل 10% نظيره انضمامها لبرنامج
الولاء زارع
المستهلك هو المستفيد الاول والشريك
لانجاح هذا المشروع الوطني وله دور بالحد
من رواجر منتجات الغير مطابقه من خلاله
تفحصه الباركود المطبوع على صناديق التمر
المباعه في الاسواق والمزادات والمعارض
بهذه الطريقه يعرف المستهلك مصدر التمور
وموثقيه الشراء من خلال قراءه الباركود
الموجود على المنتجات
نا من الرياض مدير علامه التمور السعوديه
ناصر حياك الله حياك الله استاذ خالد شكرا
لكم شكرا لفريق العمل التي تقدمه هذه
العلامه علامه التمور
للجهات او الفئات المستهدفه من المزارعين
والمصانع وغيرها همم علامه مصر السعوديه
تقدم القيمه المضافه في ادت مسارات سواء
للمساء للمزارع ولا المصانع ولا الشركات
التسويقيه الحاصله عليها همم على سبيل
المثال في مسار التصدير همم العلامه سهرت
همم اصدار شهاده الصحه النباتيه من منافذ
بشكل مباشر في مده تقل الساعه واحده بدلا
على اجراء الاعتياطي كان خلال اربع ايام
عمل همم ايضا اعتمدت الاعلام تمارس
السعوديه من قبل همم الجمارك في جمارك
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه
متطلب رئيسي للتصدير الى دوله جمهوريه
الصين كما اعت اعلام التمر السعوديه مراكز
التبخير التي تصدر شهادات همم التبخير الى
دول استراليا والهند بحيث انك تتم عمليه
التبخير المنتجات للقضاء على اصابات
الحشريه عن طريق المصانع المنتسبه لعلامه
التمر السعوديه همم في مسار التسويق
اولويه المشاركه في المعارض والمؤتمرات
التي يعمل عليها الملك سلمان بحيث انه
نبرز المنتجات اللي عليها علامه تمر
السعوديه اللي هي تعتبر هويه للتمور كذلك
في المنصات الكترونيه الان لدى المركزت
عده منصات الكترونيه
السعوديه للاعمال المنصه تمر السعوديه
تعرض فيها بشكل حصري المنتجات الحاصله على
علامه نور السعوديه وكذلك في همم
المسار الخاص بالمزارعين تم انشاء منصه
خاصه بسوق المزارعين من وسط المزاد
الكتروني على همم على مدى طوال الموسم همم
المعتمده والحاصل على العلامه بح انها
تعرف فيها منتجاتها طوال فتره الموسم همم
في مسار الدعم في مسار الدعم المزارعين
اطلاقنا برنامج ولاء خاص بالمزارع النخيل
يقدم لهم خصومات على المدخلات الزراعيه
كذلك خدمات ما با- خدمات ما بعد الحصوات
مثل عمليات التعبئه والتخزين والتغريفه
التي تهم المزارع في براسم المنتجاته
لزياده القيمه السوقيه كذلك في الخدمات
العامه على سبيل المثال التاجير السيارات
التمويل التاجيريا يحصل على مزايا من خلال
شركانه في القطاع الخاص همم في مسار همم
بس خليني اسالك عن عدد المزارع على
المصانع
واللي حصلت حتى الان على على علامه التمور
كمان علامه
بالنسبه للمزارع حصلت تقريبا 6% من النخيل
المملكه على علامه السعوديه تمثل عدد
المزارع تقريبا
4,700 مزرعه من 123000 حيازه زراعيه في ما
يخص مصانع التمور حاصله عليها 57 مصنع مثل
التربين في المئه تقريبا اجمالي مصانع
التمور في المملكه
بعد ذلك هل يمكنكم من خلال هذه العلامه
الان يعني
تقضوا على التلاعب المتعلق بتحديد الفاخر
من هذه التمور تمور فاخره او غيرها بعض
مثلا يتلاعب بهذه المساله فبالتالي انتم
كيف بتتاكدوا من القضيه
العلامه احد اهدافها توحيد تصنيف التمر في
المملكه بحيث نعمل على المواصفات القياسيه
استرشاديه للتمور بحيث ان نحدد فئه المنتج
من خلال هل سواء هو فاخره او تمور ممتازه
او تمور قيا او الدرجه التصنيعيه استخدام
في الصناعه ال- ال- المواصفه السعوديه همم
هدفها اللي هو تسهيل اول التسهيل التجاره
همم الدوليه والمحليه بين التجار وبين
المزارعين ثاني حاجه ثاني هدف اللي هو همم
توعيه همم او نقول ضمان حصول على المنتج
مول بحيث ان يضمن الدرجه المكتوبه على
عبوه المنتج بالتوفيق شكرا جزيلا لك مدير
علامه التمور السعوديه
الرابع ايضا مستمره في ابعد قليل رحيل
محمد السنعوسي وزير الاعلام الكويت السابق
واحد رواد التغيير في حياه الكويتيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم
من الاتحاد السعودي الى الامن السيبراني
والبرمجه والدروس وبالشراكه مع الهيئه
العامه
الاكبر من نوعها في مجال الامن السيبراني
في المنطقه و تشهد حضور عدد كبير من رؤساء
قطاع الامن المعلومات في اهم شركات
العالميه المختصه تشمل الفعاليه سته اقسام
الرئيسيه منها القمه التنفيذيه التي تناقش
اخر المستجدات في هذا المجال
من ضمن الينا مراسل العربيه عبد الواحد
الحميد من واجهه الرياض اهلا عبد الواحد
ما هي اخر المستجدات التي
تناقشها فعاليه بلاكات
نعم خالد نحن في اليوم الاول من هذه
الفعليه الضخمه التي تقام لاول مره في
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض حيث يعني يستمر
الحاضرون الى هذا الحدث الضخم بالتوافق
الى مختلف اقسام هذا الحدث من خلال
الاقسام المتنوعه التي اعلن عنها هناك
يعني شركات كبيره مشاركه اضافه الى دورات
تدريبيه واا يعني تثقيفيه في مجال الامن
السبراني وغيرها من الفعاليات على مدار
ثلاثه ايام همم خالد همم نريد نتعرف اكثر
على تفاصيل هذا الحدث ينضم الينا الاستاذ
خالد سليم وهو همم مدير تطوير الاعمال في
الاتحاد السعودي للامن السبراني والبرمجه
اهلا وسهلا بك نريد ان نتعرف اولا على
اهميه هذا الحديث همم قبل ما نتعرف على
اهميه هذا الحدث خلينا نعرف كيف بلاك هاد
جاء للرياض طبعا الاتحاد السعودي تقريبا
من ثلاث سنوات وهو يحاول انه
يعني يحتضن مثل هذا المؤتمر اللي يعتبر
احد اكبر المؤتمرات ال- همم السبرانيه في
العالم همم المحاولات كانت يعني جدا جاده
قدرنا ان والله نجيب بلاك هات ولكن في اسم
مختلف اللي كان السنه الماضيه كان اتهاك
اسوسيه باي بلاكات همم شيء طبيعي انه
والله مثل هذه المؤتمرات ما كانت تقام في
في المنطقه الخليج هنقول فكان في تخوف
انهم يستخدمون اسم بلاكات انه ممكن الاسم
ما ينجح وكذا ولكن الحمد لله النجاح
الباهر اللي كان السنه الماضيه في مؤتمر
اتاك همم قدرنا انه والله نقنع بلاكات
بنفسهم انه يكونوا متواجدين همم اليوم همم
نرجع الى سؤالك في ما يخص ايش الاشياء
اللي تطورت الاشياء اللي انضافت في هذا
المؤتمر همم السنه هذه عندنا دورات
تدريبيه اكثر من السنه الماضيه عندنا اكثر
من 250 براند عالمي متواجد عندنا اكثر من
200 متحدث وي يعني افضل الخبراء العالميين
في همم في همم في الامن السيبراني فكل هذه
الامور تعتبر نقول اضافه الى الى المؤتمر
في هذه السنه طيب يعني احنا نشاهد صراحه
اعداد كبيره من الشباب تتجول في هذا
المعرض وفي هذا الحدث تحديدا ايش ممكن
يستفيدونها هؤلاء الشباب من حدث ضخم مثل
بلاكات طبعا المؤتمر في اكثر من قسم يعني
عندنا مثلا الدورات التدريبيه وهذه دورات
جدا متقدمه في الامن السيبراني همم تقدمها
دورات عفوا متقدمها شركات عالميه مختصه في
سابر سكيورتي عندنا اكثر من زي ما ذكرت
اكثر من 250 براند فهذه فيها نتورك
همم برده عندنا منطقه الفعاليات فيها اكثر
من همم
سبعتيز كل هذه الاشياء فيها براكتيل فيها
همم
تضيف للزوار معرفه اكثر شكرا جزيلا لك
خالد سليم
وهو يعني مدير تطوير الاعمال في الاتحاد
السعودي للامن السبراني والبرمجه والدروس
خالد كما تشاهد الحدث مستمر في يومه الاول
اعداد كبيره تتواجد الى هذا المركز في
واجهه الرياض للمشاركه في هذا الحدث الضخم
للاستفاده من الدورات التدريبيه همم
للاستماع الى المحاضرات التي يلقيها همم
يعني متحدثون من مختلف دول العالم في
الاستمراني شكرا لك عبد الواحد الحميد من
وجهه الرياض
تستعد مزارع الاحسان الاستقبال الالاف من
مشجع كاس العالم حيث قرر بعضهم ملاك فتح
ابوابها للزوار والسياح خلال جانب خوذي
بعض رجال الاعمال غماره السياحه الترفيه
والزراعيه في الاحساء عبر شرائي بعض
المزارع والتحويلها الى مواقع سياحيه
جاذبه عبد الرحمن العصيمي
[تصفيق]
سياحه الريفيه واعده تعيشها محافظه
الاحساء ما شجع الكثير من رجال الاعمال
على استغلال المزارع وتحويلها لمواقع
السياحيه يوسف السميح احد هؤلاء الذين
قرروا شراء مزرعه قديمه ليجعل منها مطعما
وسط النخيل والاشجار انصح جميع هذه
المزارع اللي بس قاعد على نخيل ولا كده
يفتحهم
منتجعات يفتحها هذا السياحه في الاحساء
هنا الدار بشكل فضيع كبير يعني انا عندي
استقبال بعد ما حولت المزرعه الى مطعم
الكويت من قطر من الامارات من البحرين
جروبات تجيني من خارج منطقه الاحساء
استعداداتهم كبيره تقوم بها محافظه
الاحساء واهاليها الاستقبال الالاف من
مشجعين كاس العالم على راسهم العاملون في
المواقع السياحيه عندنا المتاحف وعندنا
جبل القاره وعندنا همم جوافه سياحيه
وعندنا اكلات الشعبيه
للاستقبال الجماهير وان شاء الله يشرفونا
واستمتعوا في الحسا والحاسه ما شاء الله
عليها يعني من ضمن الدول اللي داخل
الطابعي اليونسكو تراثها
واراضيها وزرعتها عندنا جروبات شبه
اسبوعيا تجيء من دول مجلس التعاون سيدنا
البحرين عندنا الكويت بطاريه جون جروبات
يجون زياره للمطعم هنا
الاقبال على السياحه الزراعيه يشجع
الكثيره من اصحاب المزارع على المشاركه في
تطبيقات سياحيه مرتبطه في نشاط المزارعين
من اجل زياده اثراء تجربه السائح وكذلك
مصادر دخل اضافيه للمزارعين فيما يتوافق
مع عادات اهل الاحساء في الترحاب والكرام
استقبال جيد وهمم حتى لو ما يطلعون من
المزرعه مبسوطين
[موسيقى]
محافظه الاحساء تتميز بمخيلها واشجارها
الوارفه حيث تبلغ مساحه الاحساء القديمه
نحو 80,000 متر مربع ويبلغ عدد الحيازات
الزراعيه نحو 27000 تنتشروا في المساحات
الجغرافيه الشاسعه في المحافظه ما يجعلها
خيارا مناسبا للكثير من مشجعين كاس العالم
والسياحي في المنطقه عبد الرحمن العصيمي
من محافظه الاحساء العربيه
[موسيقى]
توفي صباح اليوم وزير الاعلام الكويتيه لا
يسبق محمد السنعوسي عن عمر النهزه 84 عاما
بعد صراع مع المرض سنعود من المؤسسين
لتلفزيون الكويت الرسميه عام 1960 وعرف
عنه تسليطه الضوء على سلوكيات الخاطئه في
المجتمع الكويتي ضمن برامج
اليوم بعد مشوار طويل بالانجازات في احد
احياء الكويت ولد السنعوسي في العام
1938 وتلقى مراحل تعليمه الاولى فيها قبل
ان ينتقل للدراسه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حصل على شهادته الجامعيه من
جامعه جنوب كاليفورنيا في الاعلام كما درس
النقد في المعهد العالي للفنون المسرحيه
في مصر يعد السنعوسي احد المؤسسين
للتلفزيون الكويت الرسمي عام 1960
للبرامج اضافه الى عمله كمخرج ومنتج ومعدل
البرامج ساهم بانتاج فيلم الرساله وعمر
المختار
وتدرج السنعوثي في تلفزيون الكويت حتى
اصبح في العام
1964 مراقبه للبرامج ثم مديرا عاما ثم
وكيلا عيدا لشؤون التلفزيون في وزاره
الاعلام حتى العام
الكويت بلد حار اكتسب السنعوسي شهره واسعه
ببرامجه الحواريه التي تتناول قضايا
اصلاحيه مهمه في الكويت كما عرف عنه
تسليطه الضوء على السلوكيات الخاطئه في
المجتمع الكويتي
ولانه شخصيه لا تعترف بالتقاعد بمعناه
الحرفي عمل بعد تقاعده من وزاره الاعلام
في العام
1985 عامل مديرا عاما لشركه المشروعات
السياحيه ثم استقاله وعمل بالتجاره الحره
قبل ان يصبح وزيرا للاعلام في العام 2006
وفي مارس من العام الماضي حل السنعوس ضيفا
على برنامج سؤال مباشر على شاشه العربيه
عبر فيه عن الكثير من ارائه التي كان منها
ان الديمقراطيه في الكويت منقوصه وان مجلس
الامه شر لا بد منه
الفساد والمصالح والرشاوه هذه التقت على
هذا المجتمع وللاسف الشديد فاصبح مجلس
الامه نقطه يشهر عليها
كانها شر ولكن لابد منه
[موسيقى]
الانسان القديم كان يعتقد ان حركه الاجرام
السماويه لها تاثير على سلوكيات الخليل
مع خالد ازعاج
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
علاقه الانسان بصفحه السماء ومحتوياتها
علاقه ازليه فالانسان القديم كان يعتقد ان
حركه الاجرام السماويه لها تاثير على
سلوكيات الخليقه والحوادث الكونيه
والارضيه وبالغ بها فنشا علم التنجيم ومع
الدراسه لاحوال شروقها وتوسطها وغروبها
وضعوا لها قواعد فنشا علم الفلك فعلم
الفلك ولد من الرحم التنجيم قال المنجم
والطبيب كلاهما لا تحشر الاجساد قلت
اليكما طهرت ثوبي للصلاه وقبله طهرا فاين
الطهر من
جسديكما
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والقبه السماويه تتكون من نجوم منفرده
ومجاميع تخيلها الانسان القديم على هيئه
جمادات وحيوانات وحتى البشر ونسج حولها
الاساطير اسماها العرب القدماء بالبروج
لعلوها وجمالها ولقد جعلنا في السماء
بروجا وزيناها
بالناظرين
[موسيقى]
ختم رابعه العلوي
قمه العشرين في بالي تتواصل حرب اوكرانيا
وازمات الجوع تتسيد نقاشات واجتماعات
القدم
ولي العهد السعودي يواصل اجتماعاته مع
قاده العشرين نقاش حول التهديدات المنطقه
والسلوك الايراني
اوله بنك للبذور في السعوديه يوصل
مستهدفات رعايه 600000 بذره في العلا حتى
20 30
الرياض تجمع خبراء التقنيه في بلاك هاد
جوائز مليونيه
250 فريقا سبرانيه
رحيل محمد السنعوسي وزير الاعلام الكويت
السابق واحد رواد التغيير في حياه
الكويتيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]